[Musique]
des bisous pour dire bonjour pour dire
au revoir bisous politique symbolique
mais aussi bisou de star et surtout
bisous mythique mais aujourd'hui tout ça
c'est interdit salué sans serrer la main
et éviter les embrassades vite et les
embrassades véhicules novembre à saint
jean brice la bise interdite
compliqué en france où elle a une
certaine importance
d'ailleurs la télévision lui a consacré
des sujets entier exemple en 1979
partons à la découverte du baiser pour
françois truffaut la bise le baiser
c'était sacré le summum du couple sur un
grand écran
mais à la fin des années 70 le
réalisateur regretter qu'il perde de sa
superbe
le baiser perd de son importance il perd
de sa valeur événementiel c'est ça c'est
ce que je voulais dire le baiser devrait
être un événement un événement certes
mais qu'il faut pouvoir partager la
personne
la bise à ses propres codes par région
de 3,4 bisous par la joue gauche par la
joue droite
bref une culture du bisou à la française
défendue jusqu'à l'assemblée nationale
par jean lassalle en 2007
c'est un colossal c'est formidable ça ça
donne ça déclenche de saint-hélen
extraordinaire dont vous pouvez pas
réfléchi bonal pas le temps comprenez
une coutume déjà menacé en 2009 lors de
la grippe a lorsque la maire du
guilvinec vous l'êtes interdire la bise
à ses administrés ça faisait marrer jean
pierre pernaut elle souhaite qu'on
remplace le bisou par une sorte de salut
à l'indienne hughes pour les pêcheurs du
finistère c'était hors de question
tous les genres et à la clé ça changera
pas le problème si on veut dire bonjour
jai avant le jeu par épisode et voilà
fini terminé
comment qui vont faire les 10 jeunes qui
flirte c'est fini alors ils vont pouvoir
bragg et plus et plus de contacts plus
de bisous à la place des gestes
barrières et de la distanciation sociale
mais les archives de la télévision elles
peuvent encore nous des côtés
excusez moi je vous envie
[Musique]